les progrès de la marine de guerre 1914
l'une des causes principales de la
première guerre mondiale a été la course
à l'armement naval entre l'allemagne et
la grande bretagne
et pourtant ironiquement la marine de
guerre n'a joué qu'un rôle très limité
dans la résolution du conflit
au début du 20e siècle tous les
principaux pays investir des sommes
considérables pour construire une avenir
de surface toujours plus puissants mais
n'eut qu'une seule bataille d'importance
elle se déroula au gîte landes au large
de la norvège en 1916 son résultat fut
indécis et ses pertes importantes de
part et d'autre en fait aucune des
flottes de surface dette est capable
d'établir sa suprématie en haute mer
et ce fut une toute nouvelle arme navale
qui joue un rôle très important dans la
guerre maritime
le sous marin
pendant la première partie de la guerre
les sous marins allemands sont parvenus
à femme est pratiquement la grande
bretagne et l a poussé à se retirer du
conflit mais leur action était aussi
largement responsable de l'entrée en
guerre des etats-unis en 1917 avec des
conséquences désastreuses pour
l'allemagne
nous
une autre en apportant qui est apparu
pendant la première guerre mondiale même
si son utilisation reste à limiter ce
fut l'aviation dans un environnement
maritime
les premiers avions furent d'abord
utilisé pour accomplir des vols de
reconnaissance en mer mais dès la fin de
la guerre on assista au premier
atterrissage par rapidement sur des
porte-avions expérimentaux 25 ans plus
tard pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
les porte avions vont remplacer les
puissants cuirassé en tant que vaisseaux
amiraux des flottes autour desquels
viendront se rassembler tous les navires
de l'escadre au début du 20e siècle il
paraissait inconcevable que la grande
bretagne puisse s'engager dans une
course aux armements avec l'allemagne
après tout leurs foyers en deux
d'allemagne était le neveu du roi
edouard vii d'angleterre
il parlait couramment l'anglais il avait
régulièrement participé en tant qu
yachtman au fameuse régate de cos
il avait également été nommé amiral
honoraire de royal navy
même s'il avait reçu cette distinction
que parce qu'il s'était plaint que je
les officiers britanniques il rend
compte qu'elle ne le saluer jamais de la
même manière
cette distinction purement honorifique
était habituellement accordées aux
principaux représentants des dynasties
étrangères comme un marque de respect de
l'amirauté britannique
oui
la puissance maritime définissait le
statut mondial d'une nation et l'empiré
britannique tonné sans contestation
aucune la première place en termes de
taille et de puissance
même si la grande bretagne préféré
résoudre les conflits par la diplomatie
plutôt que par des menaces des actions
militaires il est toujours rassurant de
savoir que ses efforts diplomatiques et
solidement appuyé sur la marine la plus
puissante du monde
l'allemagne n'était une nouvelle
puissance blanc mondiale
ce n'était en effet que dans les 40
dernières années que sous l'impulsion du
bismarck
le chancelier de faire la prusse avait
réussi à revenir se sont contrôlés
nombreux royaumes et principauté qui
constitue l europe centrale
au début du 20e siècle allemagne avait
réussi à conquérir un petit empire mais
guillaume ii était devenu jaloux de la
royal navy et cette jalousie abouti à
vers des conflits les plus
catastrophiques que le monde ait jamais
connu
cette obsession fut entretenu par son
ministre des affaires maritimes
alfred sortir pitts tiers qu'ils
pensaient qu'il pourrait utiliser la
prodigieuse puissance industrielle de
l'allemagne du début du 20ème siècle
pour créer une flotte de haute mer
capables d'affronter la royal navy
peut-être parce que toutes les mers du
globe mais au moins pour dominer la
manche et l'océan atlantique
ce plan était typique de la mégalomanie
de guillaume ii en effet
géographiquement l'allemagne était
entouré de terres et c'est seul port sur
la mer baltique
or pour sortie de la mer baltique et
gagner l'océan il fallait pouvoir passer
les eaux peu profondes au large des
côtes danoises
si le roi edouard vii avait vécu plus
longtemps on peut penser que la première
guerre mondiale aurait pu être évitée
parce qu'il avait une grande influence
sur sur le veut mais il doit recette est
mort en 1911 et georges 5 lui a succédé
et guillaume de philippe ii donne libre
cours sans contrôle à tous ses fantasmes
et ses prétentions
il est heureux que les britanniques
étaient au même moment en la personne de
l'amiral jacky fischer un contrepoids
énergique et charismatique attire pics
fischer s'est vite rendu compte de
l'importance qu'il y avait à maintenir à
tout prix la supériorité existants de la
royal navy en utilisant également les
énormes ressources industrielles de la
grande bretagne
fisher était un adepte de la théorie des
gros canons le concept était basé sur
l'idée qu'il valait mieux tirer de gros
au but le plus loin possible pour
réduire le risque de se faire atteindre
par l'ennemi tout en lui infligeant des
dégâts considérables en février 1906 le
roi édouard cet avis n'augurait le
premier des nouveaux navires
qu'illustrer cette théorie le hms djaout
d'un seul coup tous les autres navires
de guerre se retrouvèrent dépasser les
vraies notes étaient armés de d'icade en
300 mm montés sur des tourelles double
mais ce qui rendait le de la dot
révolutionnaire c'était tout aussi son
système de propulsion
ces turbines à vapeur faisait tourner
quatre arbres d'hélices qui lui
permettait d'atteindre une vitesse de 21
noeuds mieux encore le jackpot avait été
construit en moins d'un an aux arsenaux
de la royal navy à porstmouth son impact
que si fort que le terme de jackpot de
20 le nom générique pour désigner les
grands croiseur de bataille qui fut
relancée par toutes les marines du monde
pendant les dernières années précédant
le concile en 1906 sa marine de guerre
allemande était à cinquième du monde
en 1914 elle était parvenue au second
en 1909 c'est avec une grande inquiétude
que le gouvernement britannique a appris
que les allemands avaient décidé de
bâtir dido and not opposés aux huit que
le britannique hanté possédé les navires
britanniques étaient traditionnellement
plus lourdement cuirassé armée en
artillerie que les bateaux allemands
en 1912 on décida de construire des
croiseurs de bataille plus léger et donc
moins bien protégée mais aussi
puissamment armés et surtout très rapide
ce furent les croiseurs de la classe de
queen elizabeth
le queen elizabeth était armé de huit
canaux 375 capable d'envoyer près de
7000 kg d'obus en une seule bordés
ce furent probablement les meilleurs
navires de surface de la première guerre
mondiale
ils ont s'en servit même pendant la
seconde 25 au plus tard
au début de la guerre en août 14 les
britanniques avaient réussi à construire
38 dreadnought les croiseurs de bataille
les allemands eux n'en comptait que 24
mai pendant toute la guerre les
allemands n'osèrent jamais risquer leur
flotte tout neuf dans un combat de
grande envergure contre la royal navy
après seulement quelques semaines en
1914 les éléments d'un royal navy
attaqué un escadron de navires allemands
près de leurs bases de heligoland lescar
de brittany qui comptait deux croiseurs
légers et 31 destroyer se trouvant
rapidement difficultés face à des
renforts allemands beaucoup plus
important prévenu par radio l'amiral
bitchy dans la flotte se trouvait à une
quarantaine de kilomètres au nord arrive
à très vite sur zone il détruisit trois
navires en dommages 1 3 autres grâce à
la brume les allemands pirson firent
rapidement mais il avait perdu 1200
hommes quand les britanniques mur que 35
tués à la suite de cette action la
réputation d'amiral valeureux du beat it
encore enfoncé les un peu plus tard les
choses tournent mal pour la royal navy
depuis le début de la guerre l'amiral
maxime et l'advanced paix qui est elle
était de l'escadre allemand de l'extrême
orient en asie avait détruit de nombreux
bateaux marchands dans l'hémisphère sud
sa flotte était composée de bateaux
modernes et efficaces et comptait
notamment deux croiseurs de ligne de
charles vost le maillot et trois
croiseurs légers le 1er novembre 1914 au
large de la côte du chili à cornell ils
engagèrent le combat contre les ce cadre
en aval de la mayral sur christophe
craddock qui fut anéantie
cependant grâce à l'interception de
conversations radio l'amirauté appris
que je paie quand tu es maintenant
attaquer les nombreux navires marchands
qui sillonnait les routes maritimes au
large des côtes d'amérique du sud
ont dépêché nouvel escape commandé par
s'offre d'eric sturdy elle comptait deux
croiseurs de ma taille rapide tout neuf
lavin sibelin flexible et six autres
croiseur plus anciens la flotte devait
ravitailler en charmant apens cette
année dans les cimes lwin chevet de son
côté décida de se diriger rapidement
vers penses tu as menée avec l'intention
de détruire les stations de radio
britannique ainsi que le dépôt de
combustible pour le ravitaillement des
bateaux qui s'y trouvaient lorsque les
deux flottes se rencontraient hp qui ne
connaissait pas la force de l'escap
bettany fut submergé par sa puissance de
feu les pertes britanniques s'établir à
10 morts pendant la bataille à aucun des
navires britanniques ne fut sérieusement
endommagés du côté allemand par contre
2200 marin périr soit pendant
l'engagement soit par noyade
seul un croisé engagé par 20 échappés à
l'anéantissement la vengeance si total
la première conséquence de ce succès ce
qu'il n'y ait plus aucune attaque en
haute mer de navires de commerce par les
allemands dans les eaux sud américaine
mais il n'y avait toujours pas eu
d'engagement sérieux entre les deux
formes principales en mer du nord le 16
décembre un escadron data commandé par
franz von hippel bombarda les ports
britanniques fortifiée de scarbrough
whitby hartlepool la tavelure à peine
une heure 137 civils furent tuées et
près de 600 blessés
il pleurait gagné le surnom de tueur de
bébé
oui
l'opinion tout britannique fut
extrêmement choqué par la passivité la
royal navy qui non seulement n'était pas
parvenue à empêcher l'atteinte maëlys en
plus et allemands s'enfuir à cause de
problèmes techniques de transmission
ce fut le brillant des vides bitchy qui
se charge d'assurer la revanche de la
royal navy
encouragé par son succès ils peuvent
préparer une nouvelle attaque sur les
côtes anglaises
mais une fois encore les échanges
radiophoniques allemands furent
interceptés par les britanniques
l'amiral beatty se mit en route avec une
flotte composée de 5 3 heures de
bataille
assisté par ci croiseurs légers il
renforça son lit ce cadre d'autres
croiseurs légers destroyer venue de
darwich
il savait que hyper n'avait que trois
croiseurs de bataille mais qui fait
route vers le sud est engagé les forces
allemandes à 7h20 le matin du 24 janvier
quand il s'aperçut la disparité des
forces en sa défaveur ipr qui croyait
des croiseurs britannique était
relativement lent et s'il ya de
s'échapper mais en fait les navires
britanniques il est bien plus rapide que
lens équivalent allemand dès 9 heures du
matin la flotte allemande écrire la
porte et décadent britannique et à 9h30
la bataille commence à il paraissait
évident que les britanniques allaient
obtenir un succès important mais big y
avait peur des champs de mines et quand
lui rapporta qu'on avait également perçu
des sous marins allemands
il décida d'abandonner le convoi en
permettant à l'esca de ipr de s'échapper
la bataille avorté avait coûté la vie à
quinze marins britanniques
une fois encore la flotte de surface de
rome avis n'avait pas réussi à gagner
une victoire décisive en février une
flotte comprenant des navires anglais
français se mit en route vers le détroit
des dardanelles en turquie l'objectif
était de capturer constantinople pour
libérer le passage des navires qui
transportait le matériel destiné aux
forces russes qui avaient beaucoup de
difficultés contre les allemands
un autre bénéfice attendu d'obtenir leur
ôter de guerre de l'empiré ottoman
l'opération a été conçue au départ
connaître une opération navale dans
laquelle les fortifications fiocchi
garder les détroits seraient anéanties
sud puis de lui c'est par des navires
des forces alliées le détroit des
dardanelles mesurait 65 km en longueur 7
km en largeur en moyenne il y avait
aussi une partie plus étroites où les
rives été séparées l'une de l'autre
2600 m et cette partie des surplombé par
des falaises abruptes et fortement
défendu de plus des courants capricieux
rendaient la navigation du niqab pendant
la traversée
winston churchill qui était alors
ministre de la marine considéré que
c'était une opportunité idéale pour
ouvrir un peu de frais un second front
le plan prévoyait neutraliser la retire
ici qu'à l'extérieur des murs des
fortifications par un tir de barrage
nourri à partir des navires
quand il se trouvera encore hors
d'atteinte des canons tueur
puis la flotte alliée s'avancerait dans
le détroit jusqu'au point le plus étroit
pour permettre à l'artillerie de moyenne
portée de détruire des batteries
disposés sur les rives
pendant ce temps là les dragueurs de
mines nettoiera les champs mis les pieds
j'ai probablement cette partie du
détroit est la phase finale de la tacc
prévoyait la prise et la destruction des
forts par les fusiliers marins
mais le plan comporte et de nombreuses
incertitudes même si le bombardement
naval s'avérait un succès le manque de
troupes en nombre suffisant empêcherait
les allées de sécuriser des rivages du
détroit
en l'absence de tout soutien logistique
ils rendraient nécessaire le retrait
d'une partie importante de la flotte
pour se ravitailler en combustible
mission nourriture équipement
le 10 février le bombardement laval
commence à l'escale franco-anglaise
comprenait le tout nouveau 3 heures de
bataille
queen elizabeth trois autres croiseur de
bataille récent accompagné de 16 autres
trois heures de défense antérieure au
lancement du grenelle en quatre navires
français
4 15h léger 18 destroyer six sous-marins
21 dragueur de mines le porte avions hms
ark royal malgré un déluge de feu tirs à
longue distance sur les fortes eurazeo
du capes de coquelles par britanniques
et français la taxe avait un échec du
fait de l'excellente organisation la
défense tueur est d'une qualité de tir
insuffisant des canaux à lille par
manque d'information les ali ne se
rendent pas compte que les dommages
infligés défense turque était en fait
beaucoup plus grave qu'il ne le croyait
de plus deux défenseurs les pratiquement
épuisé toutes leurs munitions
un niveau bombardements futures ' de
plus près la semaine suivante après que
les opérations ont été interrompues
il fait du mauvais temps pendant
plusieurs jours il n'y pas plus de
succès
même si leurs doutes fut reprise par les
fusiliers marins les alliés depuis
réduire au silence et 24 batteries
d'artillerie mobile turc qui surplombait
le détroit et dont le feu précis
protéger de manière imparable des
systèmes élaborés de champs de mines
installés pour bloquer le passage des
neiges
si l'on ne parvenait pas à neutraliser
les champs de mines un flop ne pouvait
plus progresser et si on ne pouvait pas
détruire les batteries d'artillerie
mobile les champs de mines était
imprenable
cependant l'échec relatif des deux
premiers bombardements navals n'empêcha
pas churchill d'ordonner une nouvelle
attaque temps face et les détroits et
détruire les champs de mil l'attaqué via
le le 18 mars 1915 et se traduisit par
un échec cuisant
pendant ce temps là à l'undd ministère
de la guerre avait ordonné la
constitution d'un corps expéditionnaire
sous les ordres de sorin avec ce qui
devait être une opération à haut
rendement devenir un investissement
lourd en hommes et en matériel
toute cette aventure se termine de façon
désastreuse en dise en 1915
on peut dire d'ailleurs que la partie la
plus réussie était la retraite et
l'évacuation par la mer du corps
expéditionnaire avec la perte en tout et
pour tout d'un seul homme
pendant ce temps la suite à la dfs
coûteuse du dogger banques
l'empereur d'allemagne véronique la
flotte de haute mer allemande ne tente
aucune nouvelle opération sans sa
permission expresse en 1916 à flot de
votre mère allemande reçu un nouveau
commandant en la personne de reinhard
cher il était convaincu le système de
codage du transmission allemande était
en vain sur
il se mit donc à préparer de nouvelles
expéditions visant des côtes
britanniques comme la grande flotte
britannique était en classe car pas flou
loin dans le nord de l'ecosse
ils étaient certains de réussir mais ces
codes étaient déjà des chiffres et les
britanniques mineure et rien de ce qu'il
préparait chasse avec l'escouade des
croiseurs de bataille de bidouillages
dans le fils offense à la fin mais n'a
pas rien avec un plan pratique habitudes
dans un piège
pieper devait prendre la mer avant la
seule principale avec une escouade de
croiseurs une fois repéré par be keeper
devait faire demi tour et se laisser
poursuivre par les navires britanniques
pour les attirer à portée de canon de la
flotte de haute mer allemand
malheureusement pour lui ce que cheikh
ne savait pas c'est que plus de 150
navires de la grande flotte britannique
sur les ordres de lancia lycos était
aussi mise en route pour suivre à
distance des escales de biture mer du
nord
les britanniques s'étaient mis en chasse
de la grande flotte allemand pour
engager une bataille navale formidable
comme le monde n'en avait jamais connu
auparavant pour les conservateurs qui
dominent est nommé hot et britanniques
c'était tout ce pour quoi elle avait été
entraînée
c'était leur raison d'être limpide au
britannique bryony qu elle aussi avait
besoin des deux victoires spectaculaires
après tendent à son temps passé sans
succès réellement décisif
les deux flottes aurait pu se manquer
dans les vases espace de la mer du nord
mais c'est un navire de commerce qui se
trouvait lui aussi dans la parages des
deux flottes qui fournit l'étincelle qui
mit le feu aux coups
les croiseurs allemands de lipper
s'approchèrent du navire de commerce
pour le contrôler et se trouvait ainsi à
portée des canons de beattie qui leur
père à l'escadre allemand vire à vire le
sud et big year de la meilleure de son
escapade de les suivre malheureusement
une mauvaise transmission d'ordres a
mené la plupart des bateaux à partir
dans la mauvaise direction
il fallut bien dix minutes pour les
ramener dans la bonne direction une fois
au contact de la flotte principale
allemand beatty fit demi-tour et
repartie vers le nord en direction de
jaleco malheureusement de ces bateaux
furent coulé par les allemands
l'infatigable le queen mary avec de
nombreuses pertes humaines
c'était des croiseurs la nouvelle
génération qui était dotée d'une
cuirasse plus légères notamment sur le
pont afin d'économiser le poids et les
rendre plus rapides
il était plus vulnérables notamment ce
qu'un obus les intelligents plonge dans
la verticale
dans ce cas le projectile pouvait
transporter des bombes ont explosé dans
les soutes à munitions
lorsqu'on a appris à beatty la perte de
ces deux unités le s'écria il a vraiment
quelque chose qui ne va pas avec nos
nouveaux bateaux aujourd'hui chères ne
s'attendait vraiment pas rencontré la
grande foule en classe de jenny quo sur
sa rouille
il se rendit compte qu'il n'a aucune
chance d'un affrontement et décida se
replient vers le nord en direction de la
baltique
c'était une stratégie risquée il avait
espéré se glisser derrière la faute de
géricault mais celui ci qui
s'inquiétaient la présence possible de
sous marins allemands avaient ralenti
considérablement cher se courra donc
devoir croiser la route de la grande
flotte par 100 travers tribord andy
miele son bateau fut atteint plus de 20
fois dans les obus anglais alors qu'il
n'est plus heureux sir que deux coups au
but
une fois encore cher décida de fuir
alors que les tirs continuent dans la
nuit tombant en s'échappant dans
l'obscurité chez refusé par la décision
des généraux de faire lui aussi demi
tour par peur des sous-marins que nos
pêcheurs n'essaye de la tire dans un
piège pour le torpiller
les amours prétend diack cette bataille
allait tourner à leur avantage puisque
les britanniques avaient perdu plus de
bateaux de mara mais de nombreux navires
allemands avaient été gravement
endommagée par la canonnade des
croiseurs de bataille britannique
les mots suivants chez nikko puis
confirmé que la grands clubs
britanniques étaient de nouveau
pleinement opérationnel
la flotte des auteurs allemands par
contre ne sortit pratiquement plus des
ports où elle s'était réfugiée pour être
remise en état
cela dura pratiquement jusqu'à la fin de
la guerre et cette arme construite un
gigantesque était devenue impuissante
en grande bretagne les célébrations
furent pour le moins discrète on avait
espéré la plus grande victoire depuis
trafalgar y avait pas eu lieu
bien sûr il y eu des enquêtes des mises
en cause janicot y joua le rôle de
fusible et fut finalement limogé pour
être remplacé par beatty
très rapidement les flotte de surface de
tous les belges iran commencèrent à
utiliser l'aviation pour l'observation à
la reconnaissance la puissance et la
portée accrue des canons qui remet la
nouvelle génération des croiseurs poser
le problème de repérer aussi exactement
possible la position et la distance où
se trouve l ennemi la grande époque où
les bateaux lâcher leur bord des à
quelques mètres les uns des autres et
est définitivement révolu dorénavant les
navires pourrait se protéger par la
distance d'où ils tiraient à plusieurs
kilomètres de leur cible mais bien sûr
plus on était loin et moins on pouvait
voir l'ennemi est bien réglé son tir
c'est pourquoi l'apparition d'avions
moins de dix ans avant le déclenchement
de la guerre avait ouvert de nouvelles
possibilités d'observation
les ballons dirigeables était une des
solutions possibles la marine allemande
chossy d'utiliser les énormes zeppelin
il dirigea pouvait non seulement
accomplir des missions de reconnaissance
et d'observation mais aussi permet de
bombarder les villes de grande bretagne
en étendant de cette manière la portée
des frappes de la flotte de surface
mais le dirigeable été lents et
vulnérable il était également difficile
à piloter en cas de mauvais temps
c'est la raison pour laquelle la royal
navy commença très tôt des essais avec
des avions a eu six l'unevi solution
était de munir l'avion du flotteur puis
l'utilisé une brute pour le descendre au
niveau de labeur et le remonter à son
retour
cependant ce système poser le problème
de devra arrêter le navire soit pour
mettre l'avion à l'os ou encore pour le
remonter ce qui pouvait rang de bateaux
plus vulnérables emertec de sous marins
ne puisse le poids la taille des
flotteurs le peu de puissance des
moteurs d'époque on faisait des avions
beaucoup plus lent et difficile à
piloter une autre solution fut tessier
on construisit un pont de bois au dessus
de l'une des tours et d'artillerie du
navire était juste assez long pour
permettre à petit avion décoller au
moment du décollage en tournée la
tourelle face au vent et l'avion de long
terme été lancée au maximum de ses
possibilités parvenait à décoller mais
l'avion il faut lancer sa mission
accomplie devait pouvoir continuer à
voler pour atterrir sur un aéroport amis
revenir faire un amerrissage forcé dans
l'eau près du navire attendent qu'on
vienne le récupérer dès 1915 ont
commencé à expérimenter mais torpillage
par avion le potentiel d'une attaque
contre des bateaux ennemis par des
appareils équipés été évident mais là
encore pour être pleinement efficace
il fallait que l'avion puisse revenir
atterrir sur le navire
on décida de modifier un croisé engagé
le furieux de telle sorte qu'il est un
pont de plein à l'avant en 1916 lui
attendait l'une fut le premier pilote à
compter sur un navire avec un avion
retour d'une mission mais on s'est
aperçu très vite que la super structure
du bateau crée des problèmes de
turbulences et de visibilité à cause de
la fumée à son deuxième avantage l'avion
des limites à un peu de trains
d'atterrissage
il bascule a par dessus bord et et nick
se noya avant qu'on puisse le secourir
il fallait aller plus loin construire un
pont complètement plat au dessus d'une
coop conventionnelles ont réquisitionné
un paquebot en construction l'italie ont
le dota d'un pont plat sur toute sa
longueur
rebaptisé l'argus ce premier
porte-avions fut en service jusqu'à la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
l'aviation navale se développe beaucoup
plus lentement aux états unis ce n'est
qu'en 1920 que le premier porte avions
américain de l'anglais fut inaugurée
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale le
porte-avions remplaça le croiseur de
bataille en tant que navire amiral de la
flotte aujourd'hui ils sont devenus le
navire principal autour duquel les
escargots sont formés
si la flotte de surface allemande
s'avéra un échec coûteux
il y en a pas de vins dits sous marin
qui joue un rôle particulièrement
important
on raconte que mme ameerah britannique
déclare un jour que les sous-marins et
des machines sournoise et indigne de
l'angleterre
même si cette citation est probablement
inventé elle résume bien le sentiment
qui domine à l'utilisation du sous marin
par les britanniques et son
développement limité d'amiraux tnt par
vraiment convaincu du potentiel offensif
de sous marins il en résulta que
l'utilisation de la flotte sous marine
britannique fut limitée un rôle
principalement défensif de ses eaux
territoriales
les premiers sous-marins qui ont été
construits devise années 1900 est il un
engin rudimentaire propulsés par des
moteurs un pétrole nauséabond
potentiellement très dangereux
l'introduction la classe des permis deux
améliorations substantielles l'adoption
d'un moteur diesel est l'incapacité
transporté plus de torpille et souvent
la classe des t notés d'une coque dont
le réservoir la forme une selle de
cheval
ce qui signifie que les réservoirs de
balle à cet institut de chaque côté à
l'extérieur du sous marin
cela améliorerait fortement la stabilité
du bateau et l'équipage avait beaucoup
plus d'espèces que dans les sous-marins
précédent de kassa ac ou les réservoirs
de ballast ict en fait construire
l'intérieur de la coque est souvent avec
l'as d'eads avait besoin que d'une
minute pour être en mesure d'utiliser
leurs moteurs à pleine charge ce qui
leur permettait de plonger plus
rapidement en cas d' alerte
il y eut ensuite les sous marins de la
classe e qui étaient très similaires à
ceux de la classe des était armé d'un
canon 12 livres en plus de tubes
lance-torpilles ce sont les sous marins
à classe e qui furent utilisés le plus
souvent par les britanniques pendant la
guerre les salons de leur côté recettes
et cher beaucoup plus aux capacités
offensives des sous-marins et construire
une flotte de bateaux à long rayon
d'action
le robot c'était rapide en surface il
dépasse les 17 noeuds à l'heure ce qui
était beaucoup plus rapide que n'importe
quel bateau de commerce lors ce qu'ils
étaient en plongée
il est encore à 7 noeuds ce qui était à
peu près la vitesse de leurs proies
il est également équipé d'un cadre en 90
minutes situé sur le pont
en général les sous-marins a préféré
utiliser leurs canons pour attaquer les
navires marchands
d'abord parce que les torpiller técher
et qu'un sous marin ne pouvaient en
apporter qu'un nombre limité au
commencement de la guerre chacun des
belligérants entrepris le blocus des
ports et demi pour tenter d'empêcher
l'importation matières premières et les
fournitures essentielles à l'effort de
guerre
en pratique cela revenait à obliger les
bateaux marchands qui naviguait sous
pavillon 2/1 rebrousser chemin
c'était la politique des britanniques
quand il ne confisquait pas le
chargement
les allemands adoptèrent de leur côté
une attitude beaucoup plus agressive la
mission de leurs sous-marins et qui est
tout simplement de couler les bateaux de
commerce au début de la guerre ce
l'affiché dans le respect des règles
historiques du droit maritime
si le bateau arraisonné n'avait pas
transmis de signal de détresse
l'équipage étaient invités à monter dans
les chaloupes de sauvetage et leurs
cargos et écoulé à coups de canons pour
éviter de gâcher une torpille le
capitaine du bateau coulait étaient
invités à monter sur le sous marin en
tant que prisonnier de guerre pendant
que son équipage devaient se débrouiller
dans les petites salles ou et sur des
radeaux de sauvetage
les marins de marine marchande étaient
considérés comme des civils à partir du
monde à leur bateau avait été coulé ils
n'étaient plus payés
il avait donc la consolation douteuses
de savoir que leurs courbes ans
survivent dans le radeau de sauvetage
étaient considérés comme des vacances
par leur employeur mais les marchandises
continuaient à arriver
les armateurs des pays neufs paraissait
crainte beaucoup plus le blocus
britannique que celui des allemands même
si la grande bretagne traversé une
période de restriction cela rendait les
allemands furieux qui décidèrent
d'attaquer n'importe quel bateau sans
avertissement et dans une guerre totale
cette nouvelle politique ne pouvait que
les amener une confrontation avec les
états unis d'amérique
le 7915 les relations entre american
allemand de faire particulièrement
tendue quand un nouveau torpiller le
paquebot lusitania le fleuron de la
compagnie tune yards lors de la semaine
précédente le paquebot et fait escale à
new york pour préparer sa traversée
non pas celle allemande avait fait
paraître une annonce dans la presse
juste à côté de la publicité qui
annonçait le départ du navire et elle
indique clairement qu'il était dangereux
de voyager sur le lusitania parce que
c'était une cible potentielle des sous
marins allemands plus tard les allemands
affirmé hier que le paquebot
transportées dans ses cales une
cargaison secrète de munitions destinées
aux alliés sur le front de l'ouest
jusqu'à l'opinion américaine n'ait pas
choisi entre l'un ou l'autre des camps
en conflit
de nombreux américains ont reproché
britannique leur arrogance colonialiste
qui était symbolisée par leur suprématie
navale
une fois le navire chargé les passes et
j'ai remarqué le lusitania appareilla
dans la joie la bonne humeur tout
l'équipage était persuadé que la vitesse
du paquebot lui permettrait d'échapper à
n'importe quel ou bottes à son bord les
passagers pouvaient profiter de tout
l'opulence de ces transatlantique
construit juste avant la guerre pendant
les années dorées du transport maritime
m
mais au large de kinsale en irlande
tapis en plongée berry scopique un sous
marin allemand veillée
une seule temps fille qui fut suivie
d'une deuxième explosion mystérieuse ans
via le lusitanien par le fonds en moins
de vingt minutes
il y eu plus de 1200 morts dont de
nombreux américains connus et influent à
la suite de cette agression l'opinion
américain devient de plus en plus pro
britanniques
un sentiment qui se renforcer chaque
fois qu'on apprenait qu'un nouveau
navire avait été coulé cependant et
malgré la détérioration de ses relations
avec l'amérique
l'allemagne était déterminée à
poursuivre sa guerre sous-marine total
les allemands étaient en effet convaincu
qu'il parviendrait à terme empêcher
toute traversée de l'océan atlantique
à long terme il n'avait probablement pas
tort mais dès le 6 avril 1917 les états
unis d'amérique déclarèrent la guerre à
l'allemagne
ce manhwa les sous marins allemands
couleurs plus d'un million de tonnes de
bateaux marchands qui transportait les
troupes la nourriture et des munitions
vers l'angleterre
un bateau sur quatre qui quitter les
ports anglais finissaient par le fonds à
la fin de ce mois d'avril ne reste en
grande bretagne que six semaines de
réserves de blé
jusque là les bateaux de commerce avait
navigué de manière isolée
ce qu'ils avaient rendu très vulnérable
attaque d'un seul sous marin
on a réussi à certain nombre de procédés
pour repousser les attaques comme par
exemple de dissimuler un puissant canon
sur un bateau au piège dès que ce l'on
avait fait surface desservant du canon
se mettait en action et endommagé lubutu
le contraignant à s'enfuir on les
applique yoshi leur succès fut limité il
fait du grand nombre de navires qui
sillonnent les routes maritimes
on avait également développé la
technologie des grenades sous-marines
on pouvait régler à quelle profondeur
elles devaient exposer après avoir
localisé le sous marin par le bris ce
moteur grâce à des micros de plus en
plus sensibles
m
fin 1917 le premier ministre lloyd
george impose à une nouvelle technique
de convoyage de l'amirauté qu'il
trouvait jusque là particulièrement
inefficace les bateaux de transport
devrait dorénavant bigard tarn en
naviguant convoi protégés par des
destroyers
où
laure joly co s'opposent à ce plan ce
qui finit par lui coûter sa place
il fut remplacé par be qui dans
l'agressivité était apprécié par
l'opinion publique
le nouveau système de convoyage suite un
remarquable succès même si cela ne
suffisait pas sur une victoire finale de
la grande bretagne qui avait encore des
pans des combats féroces et incertain au
début de 1918 des centaines de milliers
de soldats américains a commencé à
embarquer sur les navires vont arriver
en europe au type de l'effort de guerre
américain
leur présence eu un impact très
important non pas tellement parce qu'ils
accomplir sur les champs de bataille
mais surtout par le nombre qui suggérait
la disponibilité de réserve inépuisable
il y avait aussi le succès du blocus
britannique qui se faisait cruellement
sentir
le peuple allemand manqué de nombreux
produits de première nécessité parce que
les meilleurs étaient réservés aux
soldats sur le front
il était particulièrement démoralisant
pour les soldats allemands rentrent en
permission chez eux ne se rendent compte
à quel point leurs familles souffrent et
des privations dues à la guerre
finalement au mois d'octobre 1918 les
marins allemands de kiel apprirent que
leur chair se proposait de faire une
dernière sortie avec la grande flotte de
haute mer pour sauver l'honneur
c'était un plan suicidaire les marins
refusèrent d'appareiller
là
même si le plan fut discrètement
abandonné en en normandie parler dans
toute l'allemagne
il y eu des désordres qu'il fallut
réprimées en effet le lit des
bolchéviques qui avait conquis la russie
pour placer dans les esprits et nombreux
étaient ceux qui rêvait d'étendard
évolution l'allemagne
nos peurs guillaume fut contraint
d'abdiquer se réfugiant hollande pour le
restant de ses jours
la volonté de continuer à se battre qui
faisait la force de l'armée allemande
s'effondrent a finalement et le 11
novembre 1918 à 11 heures du matin
l'armistice fut signé
vous
dans les mois qui suivirent les détails
du traité de capitulation furent
déterminé dans une série de réunions
entre les alliés
ces derniers tout particulièrement les
français insistaient pour que les
capacités militaires de l'allemagne soit
démantelé la marine de guerre qui avait
été construite un coût exorbitant fut
l'abandon le plus coûteux
le traité spécifié notamment que
l'intégralité de la flotte sous-marine
allemand est la plus grande partie de
ces navires de surface seraient désarmés
rassemblés à scapa flow
e
le 21 juin 1919 des équipages allemands
décidèrent de saborder leur navire c'est
donc de leurs propres mains que les
allemands réussi là où la royal navy
avait échoué ils coulèrent la totalité
de la flotte de haute mer allemande
alors
où
on
non